a varicocele is a group of swollen blood
vessels called veins in a man's scrotum
the male reproductive system includes
the testicles also known as testes which
are two glands inside a pouch of skin
called the scrotum the testicles
normally produce and store reproductive
cells called sperm
they also produce a hormone called
testosterone testosterone is important
for sperm production
muscle strength and sex drive the
scrotum is outside the body which keeps
the testicles cool enough to make sperm
each testicle is suspended inside the
scrotum by a structure called the
spermatic cord inside each cord are
blood vessels and a tube that sperm
travel through called
the vas deferens the testicular artery
is the blood vessel that brings most of
the blood to the testicle
most blood leaves the testicle through a
group of veins called the Pampa form
plexus blood also leaves the testicle
through smaller veins next to the vas
deferens that bypass the pen pinna form
plexus
from the Pam pinafore in Plexus blood
flows into the testicular veins
a series of one-way valves inside the
testicular veins prevent blood from
flowing backward into the testicles a
varicocele may begin to form when the
valves inside the testicular vein are
damaged or don't work properly
the valves may not close completely
allowing blood to flow backward inside
the vein to the testicle
in addition since the left testicular
vein is straighter and longer than the
right testicular vein there is a greater
downward pressure of the blood inside
the left vein
another problem may occur where your
left testicular vein connects to a
larger vein coming from your kidney
called the left renal vein an artery to
the intestines may squeeze the left
renal vein causing blood to back up in
the left testicular vein this is called
Nutcracker syndrome
as a result of any of these problems of
varicocele can form in the left pampinea
form plexus when blood begins to back up
in it the blood pooling in these veins
causes them to become swollen depending
on the severity of the varicocele the
pooled blood may raise the temperature
around the testicle this higher
temperature can make it harder for the
testicle to produce sperm this condition
may decrease male fertility which is the
ability to get a woman pregnant over
time a varicocele may also decrease the
level of testosterone made in the
testicles
low testosterone can lead to decreased
energy and muscle strength as well as
sexual problems
a varicocele doesn't usually cause
symptoms or require treatment however if
a varicocele causes pain discomfort or
problems with fertility the most common
treatment is either an inguinal or
Subban grinnell microsurgical varicose
electa me to begin the surgeon will make
a small incision low on the groin for a
sub inguinal varicose electa me or
slightly higher for an inguinal varicose
electa me
then the spermatic cord will be pulled
out through the incision a surgeon will
open the outer tissue of the spermatic
cord and separate the varicocele from
the rest of the tissue small metal clips
will be placed on these veins then the
veins will be cut
after these veins are cut blood will
still be able to leave the testicle
through the smaller veins on the vas
deferens these veins are less likely to
become swollen the surgeon will finish
the procedure by placing the spermatic
cord back through the skin incision and
closing the incision with sutures and
skin closure tape
other procedures that may be done to
repair uh varicocele include a
laparoscopic varicocele repair or
percutaneous varicocele embolization